[Music]
hey guys
welcome to our installments of harry
potter theory
now if i were to ask you guys to think
of just one
dark witch or wizard who would you think
of try to think of one
got one okay now i would expect the
majority of you would immediately think
of voldemort
he was the most recent threat to the
wizarding world and certainly secured
his place
as one of the most sinister dark wizards
in history voldemort experimented with
the darkest
and most twisted forms of magic even
going as far as to split his soul apart
in his pursuit of immortality after
voldemort i'm going to assume that a
good portion of you
thought of grindelwald grindelwald
though maybe not quite as purely evil as
voldemort
was certainly evil and a bit twisted in
his own right he was expelled from
dermstrang
for experimenting with twisted and dark
magic and would do whatever it took
to achieve a global wizarding hierarchy
where witches and wizards
would rule over muggles he tortured
killed
and captured in his pursuit of
establishing this hierarchy
all in the name of the greater good some
of you may have even thought of other
witches and wizards like
bellatrix or even barty crouch jr who's
in that case
but what i bet a lot of you didn't think
of was the dark wizard known
as a chrysdis acrystus isn't
particularly well known
but he certainly marked his place in
wizarding history as he was a
practitioner of the worst kinds of dark
arts imaginable
the types of magic that he performed and
experimented with
made voldemort's horcrux creation look
fairly commonplace
very little is known about echristus
other than the fact that he was alive
during the 15th century and that he was
evil pure evil
no one even knows his nationality and
even if it was known
i'm sure no one would want to claim
ownership of him he was that bad
equistus was the original inhabitant of
the island fortress of azgaban
what we now know as the prison that
holds some of the darkest witches and
wizards within its walls
while traveling in the 15th century a
crystal stumbled upon the island
which at the time had no infrastructure
to speak of azkaban gets its name from a
mixture of the words alcatraz
the famous mukul island prison and
abaddon the hebrew word for
place of destruction when he first
arrived it was just a regular island
but he soon turned it into his own
little dark arts experiment
hoping to keep the location of the
island which was located in the north
sea
a secret a christus kicked things off by
placing concealment charms on the island
meaning that no one would be able to
intentionally find it after placing the
concealment charms on the island
a christus began his dark arts
experiments by luring muggle sailors to
the island
then torturing and eventually murdering
them before ever stepping foot on the
island
a christus was mad but after spending
some time there he became totally insane
as he completely lost touch with reality
he became so wrapped up and enthralled
in his experimentation with dark magic
that he had lost his mind and the poor
sailors that he loaded to the island
witnessed it firsthand in his madness it
has been speculated that
chris christus either unwittingly or
perhaps intentionally
created what we now know to be dementors
i could describe what dementors are for
you in my own words
but i feel that this quote best sums it
up dementors are among the foulest
creatures that walk this earth
they invest the darkest filthiest places
they glory and decay and despair
they drain peace hope and happiness out
of the air around them
even muggles feel their presence though
they can't see them
get too near a dementor and every good
feeling every happy memory will be
sucked out of you
if it can the dementor will feed on you
long enough to reduce you to something
like itself
soulless and evil you'll be left with
nothing but the worst experiences of
your life
and in the prisoner of azkaban harry's
encounter with the dementor is described
in great detail
an intense cold swept over the mall
harry felt his own breath catch
in his chest the cold went deeper than
his skin it was inside his chest
it was inside his very heart harry's
eyes rolled up into his head
he couldn't see he was drowning in cold
there was a rushing in his ears
as though of water he's being dragged
downward the roaring growing louder
and then from far away he heard
screaming
terrible and terrified pleading screams
he wanted to help whoever it was
he tried to move his arms but couldn't a
thick white fog was swirling around him
inside him if a dementor isn't the
product of dark magic then i don't know
what is
and given the fact that ecrisdis may
have crafted these
horrific creatures i think that he is
deserving of the crown of the most evil
wizard
to have ever lived usurping even
voldemort
and grindelwald ichrisdis was a wizard
that served as a representative
for evil in its purest form he had no
agenda or
goal he didn't want power or money or
really anything
he just wanted to torture for the sake
of torturing
and to this day we don't actually know
what the extent of the torturing was
we just know that it was horrific when a
chrysdus finally died
presumably of old age or perhaps a spell
going wrong
the concealment charms that he had
placed on the island were finally lifted
this is when the british ministry of
magic first found the island
an island full of creatures that they
had never seen before
dementors it has been reported that the
investigative team from the ministry
that first went to azkaban never
discussed their complete findings in
fact
they refused to discuss their findings i
can't even begin to imagine what sorts
of horrific things went on
if every single ministry employee that
went there
on the initial visit refused to describe
what they had seen
the only other magic that i can think of
that fits in this category
somewhat is the horcrux creation process
which similarly doesn't have much light
shed on it when azkaban was first
discovered by the ministry
tensions were high and they were unsure
of what to do
with the island fortress riddled with
dark creatures
many in authority thought azkaban an
evil place that was best destroyed
others were afraid of what might happen
to the dementors infesting the building
if they deprived them of their home
the creatures were already strong and
impossible to kill many feared a
horrible revenge if they took away a
habitat
where they appeared to thrive the very
walls of the building seemed steeped in
misery and pain
and the dementors they were determined
to cling to it experts who had studied
buildings built with and around dark
magic contended that azkaban might wreak
its own revenge upon
anybody attempting to destroy it the
fortress was therefore left abandoned
for many years
a home to continually breeding dementors
though it was under much scrutiny
initially when the ministry
recognized that they could utilize the
island to imprison evildoers
they capitalized on this and began
sentencing people to the island fortress
the ministry of magic felt that the
smaller existing wizarding prisons that
were scattered across the country
posed a considerable security risk and
put citizens in danger
thus azkaban prison was born
though many believe it chris dis to be
the father of the dementors
there is a counter-argument and it
involves an old tale featured in
wonderbook
the book of spells in this tale the
origins of the patronus charm are
discussed
and dementors are mentioned as well the
strange power of the patronus and its
peculiar qualities
are well illustrated by the ancient
story of a shy
poor orphan boy called ilyas whose
patronus went down in wizarding history
elias lived long ago in a mountain
village which was surrounded by a dense
forest in which a dark wizard
called rexitian lived in a black castle
guarded by dementors these evil faceless
hooded creatures
which cast fear and despondency all
around them
suck the very souls from humans whom
they succeed in weakening
for many years raxidion left the
villagers who were fellow witches and
wizards in peace
and they avoided the part of the forest
where his castle was situated
knowing that the mentors roamed the
forest they took care to teach every new
generation the patronus charm
the only spell that worked against these
evil creatures many were unable to
master the difficult spell but there had
always been just enough patronuses in
the village
to stand guard against the dementors in
case rexitian ordered an attack
as we can clearly see dementors are
mentioned
but we still don't know when this tale
actually takes place
as it is only described as ancient
because of the way that it's described i
think that it would be reasonable
to assume that it preceded a christus
but we don't know for certain
we also don't know how long a christus
lived for he was a dark and twisted
wizard
and may have even lived for millennia
rexidian the dark wizard of the tale
appears to be able to control dementors
but this doesn't mean that he created
them either
as the mentors have proven themselves to
be subservient on occasion
we also don't know how dementors were
created all we know is that they breed
and multiply the most heavily supported
theory for how they breed
is that they grow like fungus under
conditions of despair
unhappiness and hopelessness as long as
these things are present within an
environment then the dementors seem to
thrive
what does everyone here think who really
created the dementors
was it a christus rexidian or
someone else altogether let me know down
in the comment section
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]